Indiana Tyrese
Halliburton and Buddy Hill I got dollar
I'm more with James here is the
four-time All-Star Jason Tatum of the
Boston Celtics he's starting with his
money rack
you like that strategy I don't you got
to get warm first
agreed
is it worth one see like so he's heating
up now and also JT don't shoot Corner
threes
but maybe he didn't feel comfortable and
here's the sorry range for him but the
left the left wing is his spot right
oh do you know that from experiences
you've like play these guys
catch them on the left William press up
make them a driver
[Music]
whoa so far this season Tatum has made
the sixth most three-point shots in the
NBA
that's impressive
you take a lot of them off the dribble
sitting on 12. we need that money ball
okay he needs a great rack here you
gotta at least get your 20 plus
[Applause]
he should have ended with uh
Jason Tatum
whoa 20 could hold but I don't know not